one of my favorite scenes in this movie
is when you sit dick down and you talk
about the plan it is such an intense
moment so can you tell me about
preparing for that and is it a morning I
gotta stick to the script did you get to
play around at all you know that one was
really fun to do that was my first scene
I shot but I didn't know it was going to
be Lynne's introduction because in the
original script there was like a 20 20
page 20 minute where we met didn't lick
and then dick and Linn know what is that
it's one unit so it's when you reverse
the the two letters so it's like my name
look and Dennis amazed I name would be
nari Pema off but it's really peri know
you would be Amy Adams I would be back
that's soothing another boring aspect of
me but I'm not kidding okay um what was
Oh
in the beginning there was it was a part
of the film where you met them as
teenagers and that was I really I didn't
realized that wasn't necessarily working
so Hank and he tried it with just
introducing Lynne with that speech and
so it ended up landing even more
impactful II than when I originally did
it because I really thought we were
gonna know Lynne before that so but it
was a great introduction to a character
I know this is specific but what about
that line where she just kind of goes I
believe it's something along the lines
of like this is how it is for a girl
especially nowadays when we're kind of
defying that in every single ass yeah
and have to say that which with such
authority to is it tougher for you to
kind of I know it sounds like a mouthful
to me well you know what's interesting
I've played a lot of characters coming
in that generation so it's something
I've studied at length I've read a lot
of literature on that time and they're
really how how when but those are the
options she thought she had and
it is it is it's a it's a positive
change we're making and I hope we
continue in that direction you know and
it's great because my daughter came with
me and we did a piece of that scene I
had to do ADR for that scene and she's
like what do you mean she couldn't go to
that University and like I love that my
daughter was like that's ridiculous like
I'm gonna run for mayor you know slow
steps towards just making it the norm
yeah so we do a show on collider called
collider fyc and it's the time of year
when we get to celebrate these wonderful
movies that we're gonna be talking about
for the next few months and one of the
things we're always talking about is
what is the idea of Oskar movie mean to
you what is this season mean to you so I
wanted to pose that quite interesting
you know what it's fun it's it's great
when you get to be involved in one of
the films that's being touted but it's
it's just as much fun to get to watch
the films that are sort of being out
there even the ones that don't
necessarily get the same traction it's
wonderful to see the diversity of films
being included this year we've got so
many films in the conversation and that
are amazing I mean we've got Black
Panther we've got Mary Poppins returns
it's like so cool that is precisely why
I love my job
and yeah award season yeah I mean and
and to bring attention to so many
different types of films I mean there
are some there's a film out there right
now I mean and you get these you get to
see film as you might not have seen I
saw found Nancy have you seen this film
it's funny I'm gonna go watch Josie I am
say after this amazing performances you
know in a very quiet film a very
different film than sort of some of the
films that are being talked about but
during the award season get an
opportunity to see all these amazing
films so yes I'm excited yeah excited to
see all these films
you